paula the character debate she's quite
sweary and it's i don't know if i'm
wrong or right i get the impression andy
mcdowell not very sweary
you you're wrong about that i wish i
wasn't
i think it was when my kids were little
i really cleaned up my mouth but they're
adults now and they cuss
so especially my girls who are actresses
i don't know there's something about
acting and all of a sudden you cut it's
the truth but um no i don't say
normally they said you weren't allowed
to say that word on this show
oh my goodness you know
you know
they didn't tell me
[Laughter]
if i mess up when i'm working i don't i
don't know what you guys you're probably
very self-controlled like if i don't get
my line right i'll do this i'll go [ __ ]
it [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] guess where
i got that from yes
uh four waiting center funerals of
course
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
we americans can't do this over there we
can't do it here
who's an innocent question
before weddings at a funeral so there
you go
[Music]